former fbi agent peter strzok is out
with a new book today that includes a
remarkable claim
he's accusing the president of the
united states president trump
of being a national security threat
compromise
focuses on his work with the mueller
investigation of possible collusion
between russia and the 2016 trump
campaign
init struck says quote i don't feel that
i have the option of keeping quiet about
the clear and present danger
that i know the trump administration
poses to our national security
strzok was dismissed from the mueller
investigation and later fired by the fbi
after text messages showed him
criticizing then
candidate trump strzok sent those
messages to lisa page an fbi attorney
who he was having an affair with the
white house says the book is full of
lies and quote
isn't worth the paper it is printed on
and peter struck joins us now
uh mr strzok thank you for being here to
say your book is highly anticipated is
an understatement
there's a very big claim at the center
of it and that is that the president of
the united states
is compromised unable to put the
country's interests
above his own what is your best evidence
of that charge
well good morning it's great to be here
um look i do think the president
is compromised i spent over two decades
recruiting spies
and supervising counterintelligence
investigations throughout the united
states and around the world
there is nobody who has done that kind
of work who does not believe
that the president is compromised and
when you ask that question when you look
at that fact
you have to wonder how deep that
compromise is
and what he would or would not do to
protect his own interests
i want to interrupt you because that's
an assertion that everyone believes this
but what is the evidence so that people
at home can make their own judgment
absolutely i think you need to look to
the president's actions with regard to
russia
when it comes to his absolute refusal to
respond to the russians placing bounties
of the heads of our soldiers in
afghanistan
when you look at his statements
questioning our commitment to the nato
alliance
asking whether or not we would come to
the mutual aid
and defend our allies in europe when you
look at his failure to respond to the
poisoning and attempted assassination of
a russian dissident
when you look at his absolute silence
when it came to russia ramming a truck
in syria and injuring
many of our servicemen you have to ask
yourself why
on earth is he doing these actions
allowing these things to occur
without speaking out it makes no sense
for
american security i i hear you saying
that there's an appearance of him being
compromised and when we talk about
appearances we also have to talk about
appearances
in your case in 2016 during your
investigation of the trump campaign
you sent text messages that i would like
to remind our viewers of and also you
because i know you don't recall
sending them you called the president a
effing idiot a disaster at one point in
southern virginia you said you can smell
all caps smell the trump supporters and
of course
most famously you said don't worry he
won't be president quote
we'll stop it i think the question is
are you trying to stop it now
no look every agent has their own
opinion i have my own personal opinion
as well
every day though around the united
states
government employees walk into their
jobs and they leave their political
opinions
at the door they do their job like i did
my job
objectively independently and in pursuit
of the truth
but mr strzok if you're not giving the
president the
benefit of the doubt for what appears to
be problems on his regard why should the
public
give you the benefit of the doubt when
these are very problematic text messages
because multiple people have looked at
those there have been two exhaustive
inspector general investigations
there have been repeated investigations
by u.s attorneys from around the
department
of justice there have been
investigations by congress on both the
house and the senate side
all of them have concluded that never
once did improper political
considerations play a role in anything
i did or that the team did i want all of
these investigations were
absolutely done properly i want to move
on to something in the news right now
but i will point out that the inspector
general's report
could not rule out the indication of
bias was the phrase used there was no
documentary evidence of that bias no
explicit plan but there were indications
if you note that you need to note as
well that the inspector general found
absolutely no evidence of any kind that
improper political considerations played
a role
documentary evidence i want to move on
to the michael flynn case because that's
in the news right now
the justice department is trying to
dismiss charges against
former national security adviser flynn
you went to the white house to interview
him back in 2017.
the attorney general is saying what you
did is set up a quote perjury trap
did you do that sir not at all that's a
ludicrous accusation
the fact of the matter is that the
national security adviser of the united
states
had had discussions with the russian
ambassador about
lessening the russian response to those
sanctions
well before the trump administration had
sworn in
we get one president at a time in this
country and what flynn did
and what the fbi was trying to do to
understand what he had done
was absolutely legitimate was absolutely
justified
quickly through two more points the
first is what happened to the original
interview notes from that flynn
uh interview you conducted in 2017
like every interview i've ever done they
went into a 1a envelope they're attached
to the file they've been provided to
both the department of justice
to the special counsel and to flynn's
attorneys no one's ever seen him
according to flynn's attorneys but
i want to talk about the investigation
into you the investigation
into the investigators attorney general
barr has launched it he
hand-picked john durham the investigator
to look into it
we're supposed to hear before the
election before november so this is an
important question
you're at the center of it potentially
have you been interviewed i have not
are you a target or a witness well i'm
certainly done nothing wrong
so i'm not worried about whatever he may
find if he do you expect
the truth i'm not worried do you expect
additional indictments uh
with regard to government employees
working on the case not at all
all right unfortunately we have to go
people will have their opinions we
appreciate you being here answering the
questions peter strzok thank you very
much
the book compromised counterintelligence
and the threat of donald j
trump is available today we'll be right
back